conseil ne fait pas de prévision de
croissance en propre il ne parie pas sur
la croissance l'année prochaine son rôle
c'est de constater les écarts à un
moment donné au consensus et de
qualifier de cette façon la prévision de
croissance qui est et de finances
publique qui est affichée par le
gouvernement donc c'est bien dans cette
perspective qu'il faut s'inscrire et
c'est ce que nous avons fait cette année
dans un contexte d'incertitude qui est
forte je pense que mes collègues y
reviendront tout ça pour constater sur
la prévision de croissance que quand on
regarde l'ensemble des postes de la
demande mais tous les postes
s'inscrivent dans les fourchettes hautes
des prévisions des autres instituts la
résultante faisant un écart
significatif et donc je pense que pour
vous le le point saillant c'est quand
même ce biais optimiste qui peut exister
apparaître d'année en année dans les
prévisions de croissance avec leurs
impacts induits sur les finances
publiques donc c'est déjà ce point-là
sur lequel je voudrais attirer votre
attention biais optimiste systématique
ou non c'est vraiment une question
aujourd'hui pour les prévisions qui sont
sous-jacentes aux lois de finances dans
le détail hein sur le le projet de loi
de
finances le le Haut Conseil a poter un
certain nombre d'éléments sur le
déficit la prévision de recette qui
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président découle de l'encha des
enchaînements macro-économiques qui sont
sous-jacents à la prévision de
croissance donc une croissance plus
élevée et également un contenu en emploi
taxable de la croissance qui est aussi
assez riche donc tout ça fait une
prévision de recette que l'on peut
considérer comme étant dans le haut de
la fourchette
sur la dépense le Haut Conseil a pointé
à relevé he le les effets de de
suppression des mesures de soutien en
matière
énergétique pour relever
également au-delà de ces économies qui
sont bel et bien inscrites dans le
projet de loit de finance il y a peu
d'économie structurelle
documenté dans la trajectoire de
finances publiqu en 2024 et même au-delà
et en résultant de tout ça le Haut
Conseil relève la fragilité de la
trajectoire de désendettement affiché à
partir de de 2024 et relève qu'en 2023
la baisse du du ratio dette sur PIB est
quand même beaucoup imputable au
surgissement de
l'inflation